my job tonight is to announce the 43rd
annual best picture award the first was
wings the forty second winner was
Midnight Cowboy and in between the
winners included such purely escapist
films as Grand Hotel that happened one
night around the world in 80 days
musicals such as a great Ziegfeld The
Sound of Music my fair lady West Side
Story Oliver spectacles like Gone with
the Wind and Ben Hur Lawrence of Arabia
Bridge on the River Kwai classics like
Hamlet and Tom Jones pictures about
ordinary people like Marty and mrs.
Miniver the best years of our lives
pictures are human significance like All
Quiet on the Western Front From Here to
Eternity on the waterfront a man for all
season and some that defy classification
going my way All About Eve Rebecca the
apartment and Casablanca it's a pretty
impressive list isn't it and the most
impressive thing about it is it's great
diversity the five nominees for the best
picture in this the 43rd year display an
equally wide range of content and
approach which is a healthy sign for
both the movie makers and the movie
goers the film's our love story produced
by Howard G Minsky
Airport produced by Ross hunter
five Easy Pieces produced by Bob
Rafelson and Richard Wexler
paten produced by Frank McCarthy
mash produced by Ingo Preminger
they have the envelope please your zoobi
doobi do the winner is Patton Frank
McCarthy
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I accept this award cheerfully
on the note do arrests with deep
obligations and thanks to many
particularly to the xanax father and son
who gave the patent project their
confidence and support
during the 20 years which have elapsed
since I first proposed it thank you
thank you thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
in addition to the six countries which
just saw the awards program it will be
viewed on tape or film in over 30 more
by a quarter of a billion people in all
we'll be back with you about a year from
tonight in the meantime see you at the
movies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the 43rd annual Academy Awards
brought to you by improve Maxim now with
even more fresh perk flavor and by
Listerine antiseptic kills germs that
can cause bad breath lasts for hours and
by texaco and the many thousands of
texaco retailers and distributors in all
50 states
Hank's M speaking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]